لا أستطيع أن أقول إنني سافرت إلى أي
مكان سيكون صعبًا مثل
أوسكار ،
لقد رأيت طيور البطريق في مناسبتين
على مدرجنا ،
فأنا أعمل مع
الصحراء وأنا مدير عمليات
القطب الجنوبي في أنتاركتيكا
[موسيقى]
كل شيء يجب أن  تعال إذا لم تكن هناك
صدمة من أن الناس يرقصون
دون طريقتهم الخاصة ،
فلا يمكننا فعل أي شيء
يأتي من خلال ذلك مع موظفينا ،
إنه بالتأكيد
لا يشبه المطار القياسي الخاص بك في
كل موسم نقوم
ببنائه ، وهو أمر مستمر
أننا نحافظ على
كل الترسانة  أنتاركتيكا تطفو في
اتجاه المحيط ،
وهذا يعني أننا نعود حوالي 18 دقيقة على مدار
العام
كل عام ،
وتتمثل إحدى أكبر مشكلاتنا في
الحرارة عندما يصل المدرج إلى
درجة حرارة معينة لا يمكننا هبوط الطائرات
بعد الآن لأنه غير مستقر.  ومن
الواضح أنه زلق
للغاية لكل رحلة نقوم بها لاختبار الاحتكاك ،
ثم في كل موسم سنجري
رادارًا لاختراق الأرض للتأكد من
عدم وجود مكثفات أو أي شيء
تحت المدرج
لدينا  هبطت للتو على المدرج 175.
[موسيقى]
الدفاع عن جوائز الأوسكار لتوم إنان
مغامرة ضخمة في
كل مرة أنزل فيها من تلك الطائرة ما
زلت أشعر بنفس الشعور بالحرب العادلة
[الموسيقى] ،
إنه المكان الأكثر روعة للعيش فيه
لفترة قصيرة